REMEMBER, KAWHI LEONARD LEFT
FAIRLY EARLY.
THAT'S THE FOUL ON GEORGE.
NUMBER TWO.
SO LEONARD REPLACES HIM.
MARCUS MORRIS WILL MAN THE
MIDDLE.
>> Greg: KAWHI LEONARD ONLY
THREE FIELD GOAL ATTEMPTS, AND
TWO POINTS HERE, AND GREAT
DEFENSE THERE BY COUSINS.
>> Ian: MORRIS JUST TAKES IT
AWAY, RUNS THE FLOOR, AND, YEAH,
YOU ARE RIGHT.
WHAT A PLAY!
DEMARCUS COUSINS IN THERE AND
MAKING THINGS HAPPEN.
AGAIN, DID NOT SEE THE FLOOR IN
THE FIRST ROUND.
AND NOW TYRONN LUE IS MAKING
CHANGES.
>> Greg: RUNNING THE FLOOR AFTER
THE GREAT DEFENSIVE EFFORT, ABLE
TO TAKE THE HIT AND GET THE
FINISH IN.
THAT WAS TERRIFIC HANTS HANDS
THERE DEFENSIVELY BY COUSINS.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED RUNNING
THAT FLOOR.
THAT'S WHAT WE TALK ABOUT, CAN
YOU CONVERT OFF THE GOOD DEFENSE
IN TRANSITION?
THAT WAS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF IT
THERE BY THE CLIPPERS.
>> Ian: TYRONN LUE, WHO REALLY
DID OUTSTANDING WORK IN THAT
DALLAS SERIES, THE TEAM NEVER
LOST HOPE, DOWN 0-2, DOWN 3-2,
HAVING TO GO TO DALLAS TO KEEP
THE SERIES ALIVE AND THEN WIN A
GAME SEVEN.
HE PUSHED ALL THE RIGHT BUTTONS.
THAT SHOT DOESN'T GO.
THE MISS BY INGLES.
AND THE CLEAR BY COUSINS.
RONDO HITS THE DECK.